I'm very pleased to tell you the
nominees for outstanding performance by
an actor in a leading role and to remind
you that each of them has given the
screen a remarkable body of work during
their careers those nominees are Dustin
Hoffman
the graduate the unforgettable ratso
Rizzo and Midnight Cowboy and on through
the centenarian Indian chief and Little
Big Man the strange and courageous
prisoner and Papillon the charismatic
and controversial Lenny Bruce and the
brilliant reporter in all the
President's Men and now this year Kramer
vs Kramer Jack Lemmon we've watched
through the years of comedy beginning
with mr. Roberts and son like it hot and
seen him become all of us in America at
times and the roles he's played
desperate searching frantic lost
befuddled and eventually caught up in
the largest issues that will perhaps
ever face mankind in the picture for
which he has nominated this year the
China Syndrome
Al Pacino his virtually a specialist in
roles that show the darker side of
contemporary life he has brought to
every role an intensity that deepens the
screen and broadens the human experience
his films have included panic in needle
park scarecrow Serpico Godfather's
one-in-two Dog Day Afternoon
and the role for which he is nominated
tonight the young lawyer in and justice
for all
Roy Scheider if there is a sort of every
man among these actors it is he his film
roles have been earthy accessible
vulnerable imperfect men but clearly and
recognizably human beings all his films
have included Clute the French
Connection Jaws the sorcerer and tonight
he is nominated for his role in all that
jazz
and Peter Sellers
cymbals in part of our language think
for instance of dr. Strangelove and the
bumbling but invincible Inspector
Clouseau it would appear that he has
added another unforgettable character to
his collection this year with the
performance for which he has nominated
tonight Chauncey Gardiner in being there
and the winner is Dustin Hoffman
thank you he has no genitalia and he's
holding a sword
I'd like to thank my parents for not
practicing birth control
I'm up here with mixed feelings I've
been critical of the Academy and for
reason I'm deeply grateful for the
opportunity to be able to work I'm
greatly honored for being chosen by the
producer Stanley Jaffe and the director
Bob Benton and to have worked in a
family with them and with Meryl and with
Justin who if he loses again we'll have
to give him a Lifetime Achievement Award
and to Jane Alexander and to Jerry
greenberg and to Nestor and to the crew
on the film who was part of that family
and to the crew and to the directors
like Bob Fosse and Mike Nichols and John
Schlesinger that I've worked with before
we are laughed at when we are up here
sometimes for thanking but when you work
on a film you discover that there are
people who are giving that artistic part
of themself that goes beyond a paycheck
and they are never up here and many of
them are not members of the Academy and
we never hear of them but this Oscar is
a symbol I think and it is given for
appreciation from those people whom we
never see they are part of our life I
refuse to believe that I beat Jack
Lemmon that I beat Al Pacino that I beat
Peter Sellers I refuse to believe that
Robert Duvall lost we are a part of our
artistic family there are 60,000 actors
in this Academy pardon me in the Screen
Actors Guild and probably a hundred
thousand in equity and most actors don't
work and a few of us are so lucky
to have a chance to work with writing
and to work with directing because when
you're a broke actor you can't write you
can't paint you have to practice accents
while you're driving a taxicab and to
that artistic family that strives for
excellence none of you have ever lost
and I am proud to share this with you
and I thank you
they could all agree that was
beautifully set for those of you just
join us at home this is day 164 of the
Oscar telecast
America has not forgotten you and
President Carter is working on a plan
for your release